all white people are racist each and
every
one racist we are today we're going to
do a test it's made um
it's a legit test to see if you're
racist
how many racisms do you have you can do
the test as well to see
uh i hope i have zero racism i think
i think i do at least i think i do but
at the same time
apparently fidget spinners are a white
supremacist
white supremacist symbol now so
you know who knows this could go either
way who know who
let's do this which statement best
describes
you i strongly prefer
okay well i'm kidding i'm kidding i like
white and black people equally i like to
think that's what i think at least
please rate how warm or cold you feel to
warm
the following group very warm
very warm so far i feel like i'm doing
pretty well
in getting what you want it is sometimes
necessary to use force against other
group
well i mean yeah
[ __ ] i feel like i'm failing this god
damn it only if they use force as well
okay an eye for an eye am i right
no okay great no one group should
disagreement
no one group should dominate society
this is some heavy heavy ass questions
all right i haven't thought about enough
about this
i i feel like i wouldn't say strongly
agree but i feel like i i moderately
agree with that
sometimes other groups must be kept in
their place okay well now
strongly disagree with that well then
then again there's isis you know what
i don't know what [ __ ] god damn it ah
[ __ ] i i can't i can't honestly say i
strongly
i slightly agree why am i filming this
we should strive to make incomes uh
strongly agree
our country needs a powerful leader in
order to destroy the radical and immoral
currents prevailing in society today i
disagree
i slightly disagree i don't think a
powerful leader is necessary
facts show that we have to be harder
against crime and sexual immorality
okay fine is it better to accept bad
literature
than to censor it strongly agree
just because i don't agree with it
doesn't mean i should censor it
uh that one that one is the only one i
feel i can strongly
actually put myself behind the rest of
these uh i might want to adjust later
okay
many good people challenge the state
criticize the church and ignore the
normal way of living
many good people um i agree it would be
best
if newspaper were censored so that
people would not be able to get
hold of destructive and this strongly
disagree what the [ __ ]
okay here we go in the next tax task
you'll be presented
with a set of words okay black people
faces of black people white people
faces the white people again oh what
put your okay
okay oh god do i have to guess who they
are what the [ __ ] is this tess
i think black i think white i think
black
i think white i think black i think
god damn it oh my god this is terrible
why am i doing this white
white white white white
ah black why ah [ __ ]
oh my god did i do it
see the above categories have changed oh
you're trying to mind [ __ ] me with
what's good and bad
okay fix the error by hitting the
okay all right awful bad
bad good bad good
bad this is so weird
oh my god
[Music]
i'm so nervous
okay i think i did good wait what
white people or black people good or bad
you f
they want me to be racist why aren't
they putting white people will dead
okay it's like they know it's like they
know some
insecure white guys sitting here like
please i hope i'm not racist
i swear i'm not okay um
what black people isn't it sort of
racist to put black people with bad
okay i think i'm doing okay
uh good black
good good i mean
no
[Music]
i can't upload this video
[ __ ] i'm focused as [ __ ] because i don't
want to be racism
[ __ ] this test man
how did they judge me from this i don't
understand
bad good ah ah god
you see what is i feel like they're in
my head
oh my god okay notice above there are
only two categories
they have switch positions okay oh my
god so it's opposite now
okay okay easy not a problem
i'm not racist white black black
black black that's the same image white
black
white black okay come on not racist
white white white white
black white black
is that k or psi i'm kidding i'm kidding
god damn it
i'm not doing well okay why ah i'm so
nervous
you guys i'm legit nerve okay okay so
now white people are bad and black
people are good
[ __ ] this test this mind [ __ ] me it's
[ __ ] mindful
you get out of my head i feel like
thought police
made this game god damn it okay all
right
[Music]
this
oh god
no
[Music]
okay i'm this is easy because all i have
to do is think that white people are bad
bad bad bad bad
i'm literally going in my head white
people are bad white people are bad
when people are bad what
no [ __ ] [ __ ] i am so nervous because i
did not do very well
i oh my god this is it
this is the wall street journal what
they've been waiting for i'm a male does
that matter does that matter to how
racist i am
oh my stomach hurts i'm so nervous am i
less
racist if i'm from a different place in
the world
where the [ __ ] am i okay there am i
polite i guess i'm neutral
does do they have a youtuber here oh
look they do
no religion not at all i got a
i got a graduate diploma in engineering
okay sweden oh my god come on
sweden come on sweden here we go my
result
okay why are we still here
just to suffer every night
i can feel my leg and my arm
[ __ ] god damn it
your data suggests a moderate automatic
preference for white people
god damn what the [ __ ]
you don't know that about me okay
listen you don't god damn it [ __ ]
wall street polygon please
[ __ ] uh ah it's j
it's just a test the interpretation is
described as automatic
for white if you responded faster when
faces of white people
and good words were classified with the
same key
than when faces of black people and good
words were
classified that's so stupid that doesn't
even make any sense
well god damn it why did i do this why
did i think this was a good idea
i'll let you guys know in the comments i
really don't think
i i am actually racist i know i can say
that
and this data is telling me opposite but
you try it
and see if you get i'm sure i'm sure
we're all racist
we're all racist a little bit okay
aren't we all racist it's okay i'm
trying to dig myself
out i can't do it help leave a like for
racist
i mean [ __ ] ah
i guess they were right about fidget
spinners i guess they were right
[ __ ]